Welcome back to State of the Union.
I'm Jake Tapper.
On Monday,
the House January six select
committee will meet for one last
And a source tells CNN
members are set to vote on refer
at least three criminal charges
to the Justice Department
against Donald Trump,
including insurrection,
obstruction of an official proce
and conspiracy
to defraud the federal governmen
Joining us now,
a member of the January six comm
the current chairman of the Hous
Intelligence Committee, Adam Sch
Thank you so much for being here
Appreciate it.
So you're a former federal prose
before you became a member of Co
Do you think the evidence is the
that Donald Trump committed
any of the crimes I just mention
and that the cases are prosecuta
You could get a conviction.
I think that the evidence is the
that Donald Trump committed
criminal offenses in connection
with his efforts to overturn the
and viewing it as a former prose
I think there's
sufficient evidence
to to charge the president to ge
Well,
I don't know what
the Justice Department has.
I do know what's in the public r
The evidence seems pretty plain
But I would want
to see the full body of evidence
if I were in the prosecutor's
shoes to make a decision But,
you know,
this is someone who in multiple
tried to pressure
state officials to find votes
that didn't exist.
This is someone who tried to int
with a joint session,
even inciting a mob
to attack the Capitol.
If that's not criminal, then
then I don't know what is.
So you're going to vote
yes on insurrection and referrin
insurrection, obstruction
of an official proceeding
and conspiracy
to defraud the federal governmen
All three.
I can't comment on what referral
we're going to make.
We will have a vote on referrals
as well as
approving our overall report.
But I can tell you that
our process has been to look met
at the evidence
and compare it to various statut
Is there sufficient evidence
as to each element of a particul
We're not referring,
or at least we'll be voting to r
everyone.
We think there may be evidence
because we want to focus on thos
for which we believe
there's the strongest evidence.
So I know you can't speak
for the whole committee
but I'm talking about how you pe
are going to vote.
You're still not going to.
Well, let me just say
I'm happy to share my personal v
which is a
do you think he committed
insurrection, obstruction
of an official proceeding and co
to defraud the federal governmen
You know,
I don't want to telegraph too mu
what we're considering.
But, you know, I will say that I
the president has violated multi
criminal laws.
And I think you have to be treat
like any other American
who breaks the law,
and that is yet to be prosecuted
The insurrection charge is inter
It's a specific federal statute.
No one has been charged with ins
related to January six,
not even the Oath Keepers
who were charged
with seditious conspiracy,
which is a pretty serious charge
Can you explain the charge?
The crime of insurrection? Yeah,
there are really three
provisions, three processes
for dealing with insurrection
by a president.
There's the criminal statute
that you mentioned.
There's the 14th Amendment,
which makes a commission of insu
a bar to holding office.
And then there's the impeachment
And in terms of a criminal statu
if you can prove that someone in
insurrection, that is,
they incited violence
against the government,
or they gave aid and comfort to
who did that violates that law.
And
and if you look at Donald Trump'
and you match them up
against the statute, it's
a pretty good match.
I realize that statute hasn't
been used a long time.
But then when have
we had a president
essentially incite an attack
on his own government?
There's some talk
also of your committee
referring to the House Ethics Co
some members of the House
of Representatives
who may have participated
in the insurrection in some way
and refused to comply
with the investigation.
Pennsylvania Congressman
Scott Perry comes to mind.
He referred Jeffrey Clark,
who was this kind of obscure
lawyer, tried to
he was,
I guess, part of this conspiracy
to get him in some way, to get h
Jeffrey Clark to become
head of the Justice Department
so he would
weaponize the Justice Department
Is that also on the docket tomor
voting to refer
for House ethics investigation,
your fellow members of Congress,
some of them.
We will also be considering
what's the appropriate remedy
for members of Congress
who ignore a congressional subpo
as well as the evidence that was
so pertinent
to investigation and
why we wanted to bring them in.
So that will be something
we'll be considering tomorrow.
You know,
we have weighed
what is what is the remedy
for members of Congress
Is it
a criminal probe
to another branch of government
or is it better that the Congres
police its own censure?
Well, censure
was something that we have consi
ethics.
Referrals is something we've con
And we'll be discussing tomorrow
what our decision is.
Former President Trump
is under other investigations
you alluded to the one in Georgi
from the district attorney of th
there, a dead juror, a
Georgia grand jury.
Grand jury is winding down
its investigation into Trump's
role in trying to get
the secretary of state
to find enough votes to flip the
Does the Mar
a Lago documents investigation
moving forward
after the federal judge
remove the special master?
There's also the special counsel
that's been appointed.
Do you think
that Donald Trump is going to fa
some kind of criminal charges
in the coming months?
Independent from your investigat
The short answer is, I don't kno
I think that he should
I think you should face
the same remedy force of law
that anyone else would
But I do worry that it it may ta
he is no longer
politically relevant
for justice to be served.
That's not the way
it should be in this country.
But
there seems to be
an added evidentiary burden
with someone
who has a large enough following
and that simply should not be th
But I find it hard
otherwise to explain
why almost two years
from the events of January 6th
and with the evidence
that's already in the public dom
why the Justice Department hasn'
moved more quickly than it has.
I want to turn to another topic,
because right now, as you know,
the end of the year,
and there are all these efforts
to bring legislation
that has not been
brought to the floor of the Sena
or the House for a vote
and put it in the omnibus bill
or the spending bill.
Senators Amy Klobuchar and Chuck
Grassley are pushing to include
antitrust legislation
in the omnibus
to rein in the monopolistic
behaviors of of companies
big tech, Apple, Google, Amazon
that hurts smaller companies.
It seems from the reporting
I've been able to do that
some of the obstacles
to this happening,
even a vote
on it in the Senate are Democrat
Chuck Schumer
and a bunch of House Democrats
from your home state of Californ
They're not you,
but other California Democrats.
And I have to say, I'm surprised
that these big tech companies
give a lot of campaign cash.
But isn't
the Democratic Party supposed to
for this fundamental fairness,
anti monopolistic behavior compe
Absolutely. And we do.
Now, I don't know the particular
of what they're proposing
to include the omnibus,
and that may be the problem.
I mean, these are not simple iss
I'm particularly concerned,
though, about the practice
some of the large tech
companies have of
whenever there is a
budding promising new entrant
into the market
they buy them out because they d
necessarily want to develop thei
line themself,
but they don't want the competit
And we should absolutely take ai
and other
anticompetitive actions of big t
And I think
we've got a big problem right no
with social media companies
and their failure to moderate co
and the explosion of hate on Twi
the banning of journalists on Tw
I don't think these
companies should enjoy an immuni
from liability when they behave
You know,
we can't tell them
what to say or not say,
but we we gave them immunity.
We said if you're be responsible
moderators of content,
we will give you immunity.
They haven't been.
So why should they continue
to enjoy that
immunity from responsibility
and liability?
Are you talking about
getting rid of Section two 30 as
I am.
I think 60 to 30 either
should be much more narrowly dra
so that companies
have to have a clear policy.
You know, what their community
standards are and
and transparency and accountabil
how they implemented
they shouldn't be using algorith
to accentuate fear and hate and
And if they do,
they shouldn't
have any kind of safe harbor.
All right.
Congressman Adam Schiff,
thank you so much. Happy Hanukka
Thanks to see you.